the Joe Rogan experience it's not were
you at all
so khabib Tony I'm like [ __ ] yeah
finally best fight skill-wise all-time
lightweight division when the best
fights the US could ever make but same
place Brooklyn Brooklyn might have food
why are we doing it there dude
you got and guess who's the doctor
probably homeboy freaked out when he saw
blood on they deal so he's a doctor
you don't think Tony firs and be using
those elbows oh my god that's so true
doc take a [ __ ] hunt but so true he's
gonna use those elbows from the bottom
Tucson he's not scared of getting taken
down not at all not at all enjoys it
you're gonna fighting off his back he
loves it you're gonna get that I think
you're gonna get one of the greatest
trilogies of mixed martial arts history
of those three he can symbol in a way
that other guys can't miss other places
could be oh yeah when you look at the
matchups that you're just like holy [ __ ]
Tony is a perfect kind of faux fur could
be well particularly because he's so
good at submitting people from his back
went with everything with arms and with
legs I mean he beat Kevin Lee with a
triangle think about how many people eat
Darst how about that bar bow as a fight
yes he's dark cigar that's completely
covered in blood
which is so hard to do here's the other
thing you got to remember Tony doesn't
get tired doesn't get tired it's a wave
it's a slow wave so in the fifth he's
actually better than he was in the first
how is that possible what the [ __ ] is he
doing strength and conditioning why's
that other people aren't he's just
always been that way I think it's a
genetic thing I think you know I used to
train with Tony a train he would he
would spar with everybody else keep
going to guys like I'm good then go to
the bag or Brent sprints he's just it's
just in his DNA to keep going you talk
to Eddie about it like Darren's doing
six hour long practices yeah they said
there's no one like him and they said
that everybody else gets exhausted all
the people that train with him they're
all getting exhausted and he's lapping
them running hills does his hill sprints
laps everybody I mean just a freak city
like the Cain Velasquez thing like what
the [ __ ] going on right what is
happening there met boat you know it is
both Mexican - there's something about
that some Gilbert Melendez - back in his
prime I'm known for having cardio
actually he said it I think a lot of his
uh just like powerful Mexican genetic
Mexican DNA
listen man you know any endurance and
Irie says hold my hand
maybe some quesadillas pulled my [ __ ]
tamale if he wins dude come on man you
know what we're gonna have an LA if he
beats Ruiz if he beats Joshua brother
yeah maybe
I mean Canelo is the [ __ ] cannon he's
the [ __ ] man too
here's the really crazy thing ready for
this if Amy Ruiz lost all the fat on his
body how much you think he weighs like
he's probably 250 right 250 260 he's not
tall either he's maybe 6-1 6-2 okay and
that's on there so it's really 511 now
what's his weight but boys 250 you see
215 he's thick like a bowl of guacamole
yeah they make yogurt drinks they don't
make guacamole drinks it's so the [ __ ]
out of here I'm a fan of him I just
think oh did he really wasn't was he
against tight Anthony Anthony Joshua in
the first fight dude 511 262 that boys
lose a little or not or he's just like
what why dude I'm [ __ ] - I'm the
heavyweight champion of the world
he has three belts he has more belts
than wilder it's more belts than anybody
here's an argument that I always used to
make about Roy Nelson was that he could
take body shots better cuz it's like
he's wearing eight sweaters yeah they
hit like a Mack truck belly
Roy take a shot to the belly like it was
nothing would kick him but remember like
Frank was kicking him in everybody's
kicking the crow cop Rock them in the
stomach yeah yeah it listed I couldn't
find it in pounders list of 19 stones
and two pounds - 68 you - 70
five eleven 270 did you think that he
trains hard who trains hard but he must
again a [ __ ] out some Mexican food
Mexican genetics
[Applause]